i want you to be happy
but
i don't know what else
you think is out there
i've met someone
and just like that miranda and steve
call it quits
we didn't come back to be boring we
didn't come back to do stuff that we've
already done we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them you know follow
their hearts uh
yeah one thing's for sure the latest
episode of hbo max's sex in the city
revival series is definitely not boring
in fact it kicks off with miranda and
che who have been sleeping together for
weeks realizing they are definitely not
on the same page when it comes to their
relationship
you are in an open marriage
aren't you
i wasn't until you
are you kidding me
i never said it wasn't an open marriage
you never said you weren't
oh it's awkward
so so awkward i mean it's complicated
no i'm sure it is
for you
but it's not for me because i can't let
it be i'm very clear who i am
i don't sneak around i don't cheat and i
don't fly
i'm a lot of things
i'm not a homeworker what i really love
about che diaz is they they really are
not afraid to speak their truth they
unapologetically speak their truth okay
so after all that miranda decides she's
going to ask steve for a divorce
i know
so shocking is shocking it's shocking
and she does what ladies do confides in
her best girlfriends i i can't sneak
around anymore it's not fair to che or
to steve or to you
i want jay
and this is something that i have to do
or there's no che
and while fans of the show might be
surprised by the plot twist cynthia
nixon teased e.t back in december that
fans shouldn't expect the series to be
all sunshine and rainbows
you know the title of the show is and
just like that and
it's open to interpretation but to me
that means
in a moment
your life can be transformed something
wonderful can happen something
horrifying can happen we're not going to
be treading water we're actually going
to be sailing into completely
unchartered waters okay so back to
miranda she finds che before they leave
for a gig in cleveland and che well they
drop a bomb a love bomb to be exact
i'm in love with you
i love you too i am so in love with you
and i want us to be together
etie spoke to sora ramirez in december
and the actor who came out as non-binary
in real life back in 2020 teased what
fans should expect from their on-screen
relationship with miranda
there's definitely a lot to take in
between these two and the possibilities
are endless i think that these two
characters might inspire each other to
i don't know show up in a way that could
develop something really really exciting
and electric
electric indeed which leads us right to
miranda's chat with steve
i want more
more what more everything
more connection more
energy more sex more me more steve moore
are you asking me for a divorce
this is really happening really
steve tells miranda he just wants her to
be happy and just like that
oh my god i'm in a rom-com carrie okay
well
safe flight
whoever this is
[Music]